everybody I'm Anthony and
um
I'm substituting for singing venkat who
are usually introducing the workshops
from Simon's Institute but they uh their
way today
so um
just to tell you about assignments for
those who are not familiar with Simons
they are a big International venue for
collaborative research and theoretical
computer science as you might have
noticed
establish in 2012
with a generous brand from Simon's
Foundation The Institute brings together
more ingredient researchers in surgical
computer science and related fields as
well as the next generation of
outstanding Young Scholars
the primary aim of our program is to
explore the use of algorithmic thinking
and science and engineering and to study
the laws of computation itself
so now I'd like to welcome you to the
workshop on proof complexion
mathematismatics the second Workshop in
the metacomplexity program
and uh for I'd like to thank the
organizers for the work in putting
together a great program
so this is uh it is
[Music]
tomorrow
and uh Tony Peterson so thank you so
much
thank you
and a few logistics for the coming week
so food
outside uh for the before the first
token during breaks
for lunch
um you're on your own but there is a ton
of places within walking distance so
find somebody and follow them to the
food
uh they ask us to leave food outside the
auditorium
food and drink outside the auditorium
and uh if you need to leave your stuff
somewhere there are lockers on the far
side of the building on the first floor
oh so if you're going for lunch and you
want to leave your stuff there
that possibility
uh we our videographer um uh will be
helping speakers to set up for talks
and um if you're here in person just
raise your hand and ask questions
speakers okay and uh remote participants
uh I
q a on webinar can be made panelists and
speak up
and then we'll figure it out
and um
finally thank you very much for
Elizabeth and Ashley from assignments
events for managing all the logistics uh
including their accommodation for out of
town visitors
so now I'll uh give this to Edo who
actually thank you so much thank you
antonina
[Applause]
thank you
so uh yeah welcome everyone I'm happy to
see you
um soon we'll have
um
more people I guess so uh I think we
have a great exciting program for this
Workshop of complexity and meta
mathematics
um we have uh
um about the arithmetic here we have a
dedicated days for each theme so we have
the first day is going to be really
straight proof complexity straight into
the technicalities uh we have been here
for a couple of uh months actually and
we've done a lot of
introductions so there will be no
tutorials we decided to have this very
straightforward hopefully you can catch
up or already understand the material uh
so as I said very very exciting I think
talks first day proof complexity the
second day Bandit arithmetic let me say
about this uh so bana the arithmetic
have quite an exciting times these days
there's a lot of of work from different
kind of communities participating in
this established area and we've been
running reading groups about this and
there's a lot of interest from different
perspectives so this is another thing
that is exciting
about the area these days uh third day
is connections with algebraic complexity
also I think it is quite an exciting
Direction in proof complexity connected
me to
um algebraic circuit complexity and we
have quite a lot of people from this
area the third a will be set and
applications which is also an exciting
area within proof complexity and
application now let me also tell you
that we are quite fortunate because we
are here in meta complexity program and
we have a lot of people from structural
complexity meta complexity and
complexity joining us and interested in
of course improved complexity and
bounded arithmetic but also we are lucky
because we have in parallel the subt
reunion which is also the usual crowd of
proof complexity plus people interested
in certain applications so we have a lot
of people from diverse backgrounds here
uh the the last day is going to be
talks about learning and also about the
arithmetic and different uh
and different areas
um
right we'll also have uh one day for
open problem session
um and I think I've already told you
that today we're going to start with
Russia Russell with uh with a very I
think a very interesting uh work that
he's done and with Tony and uh mauli's
son and it's going to be straight into
the lower bounds thank you restaurant hi
um
[Applause]
foreign
there are going to be some like actual
technical details in this talk
um you know it's a bit early in the
morning
but I think uh is it's good to like
before we dive into the technical
details remind ourselves why proof
complexity is so important
um
so
as you know
proof complexity will be invented in the
23rd Century by Captain Kirk
and the problem that was meant to
address
is defeating Androids
Androids as you know are creatures of
pure logic
and so cannot resist a logic puzzle but
have to use automated reasoning to solve
them
so the only way to defeat an Android is
through a combination of logic puzzles
and Ill logic
okay they will be Androids will be
helpless the the longer you can get them
working on these puzzles the longer the
time you have to resolve the situation
without them interfering
so here's a typical logic puzzle that
was suggested as a way of defeating
um uh Androids by McCarthy paradoxically
three and a half centuries earlier
okay uh it's called the mutilated
chessboard puzzle okay you remove the
two corners of a puzzle can you tile it
with two by one dominoes and it's
actually been proved by people in our
community that any resolution-based
method is going to require exponential
size
uh proves to uh to show that this is
this problem is inter is not possible to
solve but a human can use reasoning
saying each Domino covers a a white tile
and a red tile yellow tile and red tile
in my picture
and there's actually removed there were
the same number but we moved two yellow
tiles and so there's no way of matching
up the remaining red tiles in
yellowtiles
so accounting or you know humans can use
counting arguments that defeat Androids
so like how long will this puzzle stun
in Android
and I have to tell you some bad news
that's going to cause us to totally
rethink the foundations of our area
not at all long
did you ask catch EBT to tell you about
the mutilated chessboard problem cat GPT
is happy to help you to explain it to
you although in kind of big terms like
an undergraduate would use
okay but then you say well how about a
seven by seven chessboard and cat gbt
says well of course you can cover seven
by seven chessboard with the corners
removed with because then they're 47
tiles squared left rounded down to 23.
and so with 23 dominoes we can uh and so
what why we have to rethink the area is
the Androids are here the barrel logic
is making my head explode
they've learned the Kirk maneuver and
they're applying it against us we have
to do something
okay so um
okay so uh anyway uh I don't solve this
problem I leave it as an open problem
for you to work on
okay
so
um what I'm gonna do is like try to
defeat traditional Androids rather than
the current traditional fictional
Androids rather than the current real
Androids
um that are soon to be done in your um
telling you being your complete Boss by
the way you know they're going to be in
your search engine they're going to be
in your mail programs they're going to
be telling you how you should write your
papers
um
okay that off my chest
the the intuition is that
uh proof systems usually have lines that
are some kind of restricted form of
circuit
if we can understand and so they have to
reason about Concepts that are
formalizable that are expressible with
this kind of line
with this kind of circuit so if we can
prove a limitation on the type of
circuits that we allow as lines and
approve we should be able to prove lower
bounds on uh on all set algorithms all
proofs using this and hence all sad
algorithms whose reasoning is
expressible within the system
so uh
of course to put this intuition into you
know to actually use this intuition to
prove lower bounds we would need to have
some circuit lower bounds and we don't
have very many
at least uh burn in the non-monitone
setting
so um
you know cnfs are pretty easy to prove
lower bounds for uh I don't know who
first proved the lower Bound for CNF I
don't know whether they even bothered to
take credit but we can use the kind of
weakness of cnfs to prove uh resolution
lower bounds uh starting with Hawking
and going on
maybe not even starting with Hawking
because they were like uh Simon had a
regular resolution lower bounds earlier
so um
okay so and then uh ac0 lower bounds uh
by
uh I tie persex tips or and so on were
translated into AC zero frago lower
bounds actually I should have put itai
also as a reference for this he was the
first uh but then uh the the latest in
the I think it was still the last in the
sequence is uh beam uh
that's wrong okay no see
myself uh actually
yeah there should be two P's is the
problem yes I don't know what I was
thinking okay
uh yes Tony are Universal authors for me
yeah
at the end here too yeah yeah okay good
and and then you go on to like what
other class of circus do we have strong
lower bounds for if ac0 with Mod PKS for
Pia Prime
technically we sort of have lower bounds
when it's a composite but those aren't
real those aren't really very concrete
okay so uh the ac0 and my P lower bounds
of Roswell swinsky should give us ac0
mod P frigo lower bounds uh due to
no one yet
maybe Captain Kirk will solve it
what
yeah okay we could put in monitor on
circuit lower bounds and then we'd be
more optimistic but
uh but we don't even have we also don't
have I mean we have like limited use of
monotone circular horebounds to prove we
do have use of monotone circuit bones to
prove
um
uh proof complexity bounds but I don't
know that we have like a general
I don't know what a proof system where
every line is monotone would be it's as
strong as
this is the strongest
okay
so uh so it'd be good to translate
um lower bounds into monotone phrase
lower bounds too since I would actually
give a general breakout lower back yeah
these are in a black box way transfer
some ac0 function load bound to a c04
here is it always
yeah so well so if we had a generic way
of translating lower bounds to prove
complexity lower bounds we could
actually do it because we have those
circuit lower bounds and as of today
unless someone in the audience is going
to search out Eureka actually yesterday
I did this
um uh we don't have
um ac0 mod P regular amounts
foreign
really disappointing and it's not
because we haven't been trying
um so uh we've been trying
just to translate the particular circuit
lower bounds into uh
into uh
uh
into proof complexity load balance for
at least about 30 years
and
the approach that we came up with 30
years ago
um is to uh you know it's kind of
natural to take the proof that Ross
profits once he came up with and say
what's the proof complexity analog of
the proof technique they used
and what they did was they took all the
circuits of that form and approximated
them by polynomials mod P
okay okay let's look at proof systems
where the lines are polynomials mod P
and use that as a stepping stone to
prove what we really want which is ac0
mod P regular lower mounts
so we
looked at proof systems like Millstone
thoughts and later polynomial calculus
that were strongly motivated as attempts
to to try to prove ac0 my P lower bounds
and those proof systems the good news is
those proof systems uh
oh so let me just Define the one of the
proof systems that's the the only one
we're going to actually talk about I'm
going to talk about today is a
polynomial calculus later expense
extended I think by rozbrock to PCR so
I'm going to give the PCR version
so you have uh you represent the
constraints as polynomials over a field
uh where the if their inputs are either
variables or represent either Boolean
variables or their negations
okay and by a polynomial as a line
you're really thinking of the equation
is equal to zero
but in the equations X Plus is
complement should be one one or the
other should be true but not both at the
same time
the product should be zero
and then your rules are just the usual
rules and kind of algebra you're you got
two equations you can add them multiply
through by constants multiply through by
variables and keep on adding and we can
measure a couple of different complexity
measures uh like the natural one is the
size the total number of non-zero terms
that appear in the proof well we could
also look at uh related measures like
maximum degree
okay and the good news is we were
successfully able to prove you know and
we as a community were successfully able
to prove very strong lower bounds for a
wide variety of tautologies uh
you usually like prove them in two steps
we prove a strong degree lower bound
and then show that a strong enough
degree lower bound translates into an
exponential side solar bound there's a
generic connection
and the uh so this this shows the limits
of using certain algorithms based on
modular reasoning uh algebraic reasoning
to solve uh cmf sec
so um so that's the good news the bad
news is
where after doing all that it doesn't
look like we're any closer to proving
lower bounds for aging zero much
and the cap is there's there's like a
couple of gaps in different approaches
that you could try to reduce AC's hero
mod P to algebraic proofs
one is you would say well let's look at
algebraic proofs that only approximate
you know maintain have only approximate
validity
the problem is that as a romance
polinski showed me in like 1991 uh such
a proof can prove any tautology
you can just approximate the tautology
with one you know or just as a linear
combination and that's approximately
true
okay so uh so in fact
in 1991 I was like trying to convince
Roman to work on the stones as Bruce and
he said he convinced me to drop it
because it couldn't help solve acrylic
fortunately other people continued
okay so uh so in the the other thing
that's kind of bad uh okay another
approach would be to add extension
variables but when we look at even
extension variables adding small tweaks
to our variables we realize that the
lower bounds that we proved are really
brittle and they break when you make any
kind of modification to the to the input
so for example if we look at Sun graft
autologies and they say give it you have
like a graph sheet the
variables or edges so it codes an edge
induced subgraph in the tautology is
that that edge into subgraph can't have
exactly one odd degree vertex
the number of of odd degree vertices in
an underactive graph has to be even
so um
okay and this is hard when he is a
sparse expander you get a linear degree
lower bound
uh except for module reasoning mod 2 is
really easy
you just like sum everything up onto and
everything cancels except and you get
zero equals one
but in
in crime any odd prime you can prove an
exponential lower bound on the size of
any uh algebra approved
if you use the original variables
if you should do a change of variables
and you define a new variable to to say
it's negative one if the edge is there
and one at the edge is not there
um
then the parity the thing that was so
hard to reason about the parody of edges
in the in the cut
becomes just a product of variables
and you just mimic the proof mod 2 using
products of variables and it all works
out and it's uh you know a small
polynomial size
quadratic size because yeah n lines and
each one have
so uh
so this these previous
you know it's not the degree that
changed we did a linear transformation
didn't touch degree but once we deal
with one minus one variables rather than
zero one variables there's no size
there's no generic size degree
punishment
okay so that was the state of the art uh
even a few years ago
I guess like in 2019
so we needed to come up with size lower
bounds for
you know how do you reason about even
like the variables that take on one
minus one or some other values instead
of zero one
uh and we want to do this uh for you
know we want work Casey zero my P lower
bound so we want to work mod P
and P shouldn't be two because then
changes the variables mod 2 there are no
non-bullying variables
okay
so uh
come up with size lower bounds that
allow these kind of changes of variables
or maybe introduction of simple
extension variables
uh
if you could even like if we could do
this take this to the Limit and
um have uh
multiple rounds of introduced extension
variables that each one depends on the
previous round variables
each one allows us to go a little deeper
into the circuit to find Gates further
up in the circuit
and so this would have implications for
this would allow us to prove lower
bounds raises are on my P but a number
of Works have shown that it actually
would also prove lower bounds for a lot
of other proof systems that go well
beyond ac0 mod P so it's a big step to
go
to have these uh rounds of extension
variables so
uh
so this is kind of like the the
challenges in in order of complexity
and uh in 2020 the first challenge was
met
not by us but by Soca love
uh sokolov uh showed a new technique for
proving size lower bounds for one minus
one value variables
um
and it it's also a way of change of
uh taking degree lower balance to size
lower bounds but an indirect way that
doesn't apply to every technology
so uh so you have to have a degree lower
bound that's very robust in that the
Restriction lots of restrictions of the
original tautology are also have a
degree of lower down
um
so but his you know so his lower bound
seemed very he was dealing with like one
minus one valued variables and a lot of
steps in his lower bound were uh
particular to
um to one minus one variables
there are also a number of works and
they're including one that Ito mentioned
to me last night that I didn't have time
to add to the slide
um to
that uh look at lower bounds over
polynomial calculus with extension or
even stronger systems like the ideal
proof system over the uh over the
rationals or other characteristics zero
fields or very large characteristic
Fields
um so uh
uh the reason why I don't just claim
that this is like the victory for the
area is that also the the the
tautologies they're looking at often
involve uh things that don't make sense
mod primes like subset sums uh where
they're not translations of CNS I think
that's the main the main Gap but you
know you could like remind me the uh the
new paper that you have that I should
add to the list
just um a subsequent work to Andrew
Andrews and all of them
yeah
some uh some restrictions
let's do this
and this was here yeah
so uh so okay so we're gonna like make
at least some partial progress towards
resolving the situation mod P four
translations of CMS
um
so here we're going to consider
um proofs augmented with just
unfortunately just one round of
extension variables we don't have like
multiple rounds uh
and they have to be K local meaning each
new variable Can Depend in a kind of
arbitrary way but on K
of the original variable so it's
certainly strong enough to do like any
kind of reasonable change of variables
but not necessarily uh strong enough to
express really complicated things
Global properties
so um
and then once you define these new
variables using some equation that
defines them then you have a normal PCR
reputation except you you don't get the
like there isn't anything like negation
of the z-i because they may not have
2 million dollars
okay
so what we show is uh we give a family
of CNF pathologies where any moderate
number you can add any moderate number
of uh
extension variables and still get a
almost exponential lower value
so there are two ranges where you could
have like a trade-off between how local
how many extension variables you're
allowed to add how local they are and
the size lower bound you get
uh if you want to maximize the size
lower bound you we you know make the
size lower bound the most impressive you
get the high end result whereas if you
have like a constant local
extension variables and just like n
times poly login
then uh you get a size lower bound
that's that exponential in an over poly
login
on the other hand uh you can have uh n
to the one plus Alpha extension
variables so
more than linear but less than quadratic
uh each order login local
and you'll get a lower bound that's
exponential and then to some power
Beyond these uh parameters there are no
it doesn't work well there's a trade-off
between the two between the three
parameters so there will be no uh super
polynomial over beyond the beta log and
local extensions I'm not sure about that
um we might be able to go somewhere
above the data login uh
we are using similar techniques uh I'm
not going to claim that we have
that part I think is is probably the
easiest to improve uh the harder thing
to improve is to go beyond quadratically
many extension variables
and what about the uh the Restriction of
the locality local extensions such that
they cannot use previous
variable previous extension variable
yeah
if you have like everything sufficiently
local
you could probably just unravel that so
like if you have
to see that depends on uh you know so Z
depends on W and W and W Prime and W and
W Prime depend on two input variables
each then Z implicitly just depends on
four input variables
so you could probably if it's
sufficiently local you could probably
claim to view multiple rounds but it's
not actually very impressive
um
and it would still just be like a fixed
number of rounds because
you know it's growing exponentially
so
um
so are there any other questions about
what what we're doing
we're our proof uh is pretty complicated
has a lot of moving parts that have to
be done in the right order but it
basically follows sokolo's lead uh
pretty strongly but
it isn't sometimes not clear how to
follow that leap and we tried a lot of
different you know translating different
uh uh different parts of his ideas uh we
tried a whole lot of different versions
until we finally got some that that
worked
so uh
okay so first thing that that we can do
that that does kind of work is um
improves so it's sokolov said first step
the proofs involved one minus one
variables that means D squared equals
one that means we can just replace you
know we don't have to have uh any any
higher Powers than one we can just
combine the z-squared terms with the
constant terms and the z cubed terms
with the linear terms it makes
everything multi-linear in these
variables every line number
uh if we're looking at General Ascension
variables mod P well they don't make
they don't necessarily satisfy c squared
equals one but they're going to satisfy
some equation like CK equals c from us
little theorem Says Z to the P minus 1
is going to be congruent to one as long
as Z is non-zero uh so uh
my P minus 1 is an upper bound on the K
there might be smaller values okay
depending on exactly which set of values
he can do
so we can always like assume everything
is constant degree in disease
so when we after we do this
uh
so so could love uh
use this saying like how close are we to
small degree
okay uh
and he used this notion of quadratic
degree which is approximately the
maximum degree not of a line of the
proof above the square of the squares of
lines of groups
seems like a strange thing to do so
first I would try well okay maybe we
should raise to the cave power to the P
minus first Power uh
but that doesn't
give you much uh directly so say well
why did he do this and uh we came up
with this idea that I'm now calling
Factor degree I don't think we've used
this term
but I think we still call it quadratic
degree in the paper
um but that didn't make sense so I'm
calling it The factored degree so Factor
degree of a polynomial is you can write
p as a single monomial M times a low
degree Q the degree of Q is the factored
degree of P
yeah it's equivalent to saying uh oh
okay so how how does this relate to
quadratic degree well if we're in one
minus one variables the square of any
monomial is one
so if p is M times Q then P Squared is
just going to be Q squared
if Q is low degree that means this the
degree of the square of the lines are
loaded
so uh so that's so small factor degree
implies small quadratic degree in the
one minus concept
so
um
and uh it's also true that if you've got
a proof where every line has small
factor degree you can translate this
into a proof that's just small degree
the you know it's
step by step
simulation
and I spelled it out uh
my census to
10 minutes so I think I'm going to skip
this
so so now we want to like use as our
measure how close are we to having small
factor decreases and so uh what prevents
us from having a small factor degree
well it's M1 and M2 appear in the same
line and M1 is really different from F2
has a lot of variables that have
different exponents uh in M1 than they
do in M2 there's no way to factor out
anything in common
okay so um so let's say that they're a
factor degree D violating pair if
they're Hamming distance in terms of a
vector where we write down
for every for every variable the
exponent of that variable in the in the
monomial is large
is larger than
they have to appear in the same line of
a group one thing that we have to like
figure out at some point is we just want
to look at the set of violating pairs
for the proof we don't want to count
them say you know even if this violating
pair appears in a million lines we're
only counting it once
so uh
and
each
pair has you know by definition has many
different degree variables that are kind
of responsible for it so we're going to
look for is like we when we like go from
uh size to degree for zero one variables
we're going to look for a variable that
appears you know in many terms here
appears differently in many pairs of
terms
and so uh okay so again here's another
idea that was in so close paper that we
had to struggle to adapt so if C is a
one minus one variable that and we've
eliminated anything except this defining
you know except the Axiom Z squared
equals one so we've sort of eliminated
the variables that it kind of depends on
or or relates to okay we can uh and we
write each line as Q times D plus r
where q and R are polynomials in the
other variables and uh so cool off
observed that we can split the proof
into the Q part and the r part
so write down q and R as separate lines
okay and uh
and like everything the axioms don't
involve z uh so they're just ours
already uh when we sum we sum Point wise
the q's and the r's
when we multiply by a non-z variable we
multiply the cube by that variable and
the R by that variable
when we multiply by Z that just switches
the role of Q and r
the r becomes a q the Q becomes the R so
if we're keeping both we've already have
both
so we can follow we can just do the
proof step by step keeping both the Q
and the r and this split removes all the
violating pairs where Z had a different
exponent
and so C has a lot it's in a lot of
violating pairs that removes a lot of
the violating pairs
well this doesn't what was the
unsatisfied axial
conditions uh okay so
um
so so at this point
so there's a part I'm swearing over so
if Z if we have like something like Z1
times plus Z2 equals one
then
the the the r part would be Z2 equals
plus equals one and the Q part would be
what
okay
so
uh so we we can't even get a start
okay so
um going to the Q and the r if we have a
a
um a Axiom about uh that involves the
um in the original pathology uh we can't
even get a start in this group so we
first so below you know this is also
following soccer loss lead we first have
to uh satisfy that say well we'll
promise that Z Prime we're just going to
plug in Z Prime equals z minus one
and that's going to satisfy that Axiom
and that Axiom disappears and now we've
got uh no further axioms involving Zed
then we can do this way
so uh so we're gonna yeah so we're gonna
like
uh
do these rounds where we identify a
variable extension variable that we want
to split on say
uh sort of remove look at all the
variables it depends on
satisfy all the conditions that they
could be of all the axioms that those
variables are are depend are involved in
make those variables kind of disappear
from the proof and then we can split
onto
so this means that we have to start with
a very robust tautology where we can
just
set a bunch of we can satisfy a bunch of
axioms
uh
um but so I was going to talk about that
at the end but um
sweeping things under the rug
so but say that um say that variable
could take one and two okay well then we
know Z squared minus 3z plus two equals
zero
it's no longer the case like if we
multiply Q Z Plus R by Z you know we're
going to get something
okay
but it's not going to just be switching
the Q and the the r it's going to be
like the new Q is going to be 3 Q Plus R
and the new R is minus 2q
and the problem is that
you know we could split these but we
haven't removed any any things that like
uh any term violating terms one in R and
one in Q are still there
in the 3Q plus r part
so the splitting works but it doesn't
actually reduce the number of violations
so we have to try it from a little bit
more subtle
so I've said that we're down to like the
lead having two possible values A and B
and we're going to have to like set
things to make this the case
okay
um
so then and we write every
um polynomial in the
group is up to like some polynomial in Z
with the different parts and so the
the violating terms involving Zed are
going to be like having one term and one
of the pis and the other term in the in
a PHA so we're going to like pick a p a
particular inj where a lot of the
violating terms about that
are in pi versus PJ
and we want to split that doesn't have
any of those violating terms in the same
in the same part as each other
so what we're going to do is we're going
to interpret since Z has only two values
any two powers of Z are enough
information to interpolate any
polynomial object
on those two values
so we can write each line as some
polynomial times Z to the I plus some
other polynomial times set to the J
where these are going to be linear
combinations of each
so uh nothing that we can like prove
that this is true but it is going to be
the case
and then we split we're going to have
the like before we're going to have a
proof where the lines are all the qis
and all the qjs one at a time
and the point is that
Qi is the factor of Z to the I
p i appears all in in the QR there's
nothing left to appear in the the QJ
foreign
and so when we look at the proof that
just has the qis and the qjs is going to
be more complicated than the original
proof possibly but it won't have as many
violating pairs
um Okay so
when we do this this is where uh I'm
saying like if we've got him
uh extension variables okay with there's
always going to be one and we like to
use D the degree as our limit for what
what the difference is
each
violating pair has the variables that
occur differently in it so by averaging
there's at least there's a z an i and a
j where we can get by splitting on Z
with respect to I and J we can get rid
of a d over M times p squared fraction
of all violating tests
and this is pretty good if
this is like bigger than like one and N
but it's bad if this is less than one
and N which is where the quadratic
limitation goes
so so capital M in the bottom of the
slide is different from the top right
oh oh okay yeah that should probably be
a lowercase
um
is the number of extension variables oh
okay
so these are particular monomials okay
so uh I said that the last ingredient
um is that we need to be able to like
get rid of all when we identify a
variable we need to be able to get rid
of all the axioms that appears in uh to
do this we need these very robust
robustly High degree tautologies
um that even after we restrict they're
going to have high degree and our uh
robust High degree tautology involves
taking a a c and a kind of random CNF uh
con for constant K and that's going to
have
um every variable appearing like in
constantly many clauses
and the Clauses are constant size and
any constant fraction of the Clauses are
unsatisfiable
so we can like get say ah let's restrict
down to a subset you know if we're in a
certain Axiom all the axioms are kind of
expendable
you caught me on this one I don't care
about that one I didn't all I promised
was like 90 of these axioms are true I
didn't promise that that one was true
so uh to formalize that we're going to
introduce variables y1 through y sub c n
that say which which of the Clauses are
actually true
uh and so uh make sure they're different
so there are enough of them and then uh
say that if each Clause that specified
by a y has to actually be true
so um what uh I think the main open
problems that we leave and they're you
know was just still a small step to what
we want uh which is lower bounds for AC
zero montprega is to um to go beyond
this m equals N squared barrier
uh that's also true like in all of the
size degree trade-offs if the you know
even for zero one variables we don't
really know how to get good size lower
bounds if the degree is less than square
root of that
and um
prove lower bounds for much larger
localities
and improve lower balance for much of
our curve localities with multiple
rounds of extension variables which
would
which would really could you know would
bring us very if not to AC 0 might be
craiga very very close
any questions to Russell
Antonio
you mentioned that you have those
results not just for PCR
sorry
so right now we just have a purpose
I hope I didn't uh I hope I didn't over
promise yeah
so in your proof sketch you had two
variable uh two valued variables yeah is
there some other uh generalization you
know how does it generalize like what
what is it is there some other idea
that's needed to extend that to
um
we we did
need to extend it to more value so we we
didn't really cry because uh we didn't
really need to extend it to the multiple
value variables because what we did was
uh we sort of like picked we say it
depends on K variables
we
were able to like remove the axioms
about K minus one of those variables
so the the two variable the two value
case was what's left so once the one
Boolean variable it's just a variable
that's left out so projecting from all
the others you've got to get two values
left from that Boolean moving to some
other pair okay so
um so we could we didn't really think
about multiple values but it also isn't
clear how much I would I would have won
this
the question last question so let me
just ask uh
um what is the strength of this proof
system
um with extension local extension
so how do you know that it even improves
on the previous one
well
so
one thing that that kind of true uh is
that you can
you know so you can like say
um in this proof system you can easily
prove like science Technologies
also like scientology's mod cue for
different values of Q depending on the P
that you started with
just by having uh and I don't think
I don't think like uh
if there's any that there's any like
proof system where we have lower balance
where that's
where you can prove uh simultaneously
all of them uh upon you
have been a growing number of my cue
so let's uh thank Russell again
[Applause]
oh there was one